Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
March 19th,
and like the line,
I'm fucking cold out here in Los Angeles.
If you're wondering about the
weather report yesterday, um,
cold does not bug me unless I'm
in Los Angeles. Then it bugs me,
you know, from and Cleveland
Farm in Boston. If I'm a
New York, if I'm in Philly,
I don't give a fuck if it's
cold, I'll put on a park. Right?
But when I'm out here in la,
it really bothers me.
It's just something annoying about
being cold while looking at a palm tree.
Just fucking bugs the shit out of me.
So it doesn't make any sense, you know?
Okay.
It's like seeing a skinny Santa
Claus. It's like, what are you doing?
I thought you were just
supposed to be a tub of shit.
How can you be jolly if you're in shape,
if you haven't met a jolly
skinny person? You know, there's,
there's a certain level of being
fat where you just find you just,
I dunno,
I don't know if you just psyched because
you're eating cookies and you don't
give a shit,
but you can still tie your shoes.
Like that's that level of
fat you want to be at. Well,
you're eating pizza and
you're eating cookies and Yay,
you have fat. But you know,
you put on a sweater and you
go, Whoa, Whoa, whoa. All right,
you got rosy cheeks and nobody cares.
Nobody's looking at you.
Nobody's judging you.
But then when you go beyond it,
when you go beyond it is when your
stomach comes out from under neath that
sweater and everybody can see it. You
know, but you can't see it, right?
Cause you're so fat. And uh,
even when the wind blows,
you don't notice it because you're all
warm with all that blubber. You know,
there's that, there's a, there's a
fucking, I don't know, there's this,
there's a sweet spot of being fat.
Okay.
Where, where no one's making funny being
fat and you're eating, I'll shift food,
but nobody's trashing you. So I guess
it out. That's what makes you jolly,
you know, oh, I get to eat all this
shit food and nobody's judging me.
Then once you go beyond it, then
you start fucking crying. You know?
I'm one of those reality shows
I don't want, I'm talking about,
I don't even want to be doing this
podcast right now. I'm going to get,
I'm not even lying.
I'm only going to lie to you.
I can't even spit it out
and fucking exhausted.
But I got a bunch of Shit to do tomorrow,
which is today.
By the time you listened to it,
you know,
I really don't feel like doing this shit.
So it's going to be quick.
I'm getting right to the fucking point.
All right.
I already solved why certain
levels of fat people a jolly,
you know right there.
If you guys weren't so selfish,
that could take up your whole
fucking week. You know? But not yet.
You guys keep it coming.
Okay?
You like, I'm blaming you guys
for this thing that I started.
I just realized I even looked at
it half of this fucking crap here.
So what happened this week,
Bill? What did you do this week,
Willie? I, I, um,
I didn't do any fucking standard.
I think maybe I did stand up this week.
I'm on vacation people,
I'm still on vacation still on vacations.
You guys sit there and you work
putting in an honest day work,
make it somebody else's dream come true.
The dream evidently was to stick everybody
in these little fucking cubicles.
Everything would have fire hazard or
cubicle is what if there's a fire in your
little doorway, you know,
there's no other way to get out.
Where are you going to do?
Shouldn't that be another doorway to the,
to the cubicle next year?
Do you have a little
latter on the front of it?
We climb up and over your terminal.
Why are you still sitting in that
fucking thing surrounded by plastic?
They can't give you anything.
How bout like,
can they make your mouse may not have
like wood or maybe some sort of precious
metal to somehow act like they
give a fuck about you on any level?
Yeah.
Do you know why? I have a, uh,
I live in this old house now,
this old houses fucking old,
this old houses, old wiring.
This old house says fucked up plum
in and Billy's got to pay for it.
Eh,
houses,
got little garage and
I got a big fat truck.
And every time it is, I
started saying, God damn, fuck,
I can't fucking get it in the garage.
So you know what I did the other day?
I said, hey, who knows how
to make garage doors wider.
And I found somebody, I
found somebody on, uh,
make my garage doors wider.com and the
person came over and they made my garage
doors wider and I backed
my fucking truck in there,
you know,
fucking like butter.
So you guys don't have,
listen to me bitch about that
against an opposite and they go on,
this is fucking great. You know,
I can put my truck in there,
I don't have to worry about it,
you know,
and there's no problems.
So what do I do?
I fucking jump in the Prius c of the
day, you know, the ying and the Yang.
I got the gas guzzler and I got the, Oh
my God, it's like a tree kind of car.
So I'm going to go down and watch some
final four fucking action and would have
a march madness, whatever
you call it. And uh,
you know, as you guys know, I'm
not a big fan of basketball.
I love the first 97% of it.
It's that last 3% with the 58 timeouts
and the fouls and the commercials.
You know,
I watched the game today.
It was one of the worst
sporting experiences I've
ever had. I watched St Louis,
uh, the Saint Louis fairies or something
like that. There was some sort of a,
the gremlins versus the,
the Michigan.
Okay.
Okay. 20 minutes. First half,
20 minutes. Second half.
Okay. The first, I don't know,
38 minutes of the game or not even 37
minutes of the game. I don't know what to,
it seemed like it took 90 minutes
to play is flying. And I'm like,
this is why I love college basketball
as opposed to the excruciating,
48 minutes of NBA hoop. And then what
happens to final fucking three minutes?
I swear to God it took 50 minutes to play.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, they're
up by seven. It's over.
Wow.
That took 0.8 seconds off the clock
goes little lied for a one. And what?
Okay.
Fucking guy misses the ball.
He throws it down. Right?
Fucking files another guy.
Right?
Okay.
Fucking I,
I had my shoes on.
I'm trying to leave cause I gotta get
my buddy a ride cause I got shit to do,
but we want to see the end of the fucking
game and I swear to God the final 45
seconds, it took like six
minutes to play, 45 seconds.
And I know every once in a while somebody
can hit that big shot and everybody
goes, oh shit in a
buffalo wild wings. Right?
And then you slutty waitress comes over
with a ref shirt tied off, you know,
just done at the teddies cleavage
showing, hey guys, how are ya?
You want some more wings?
Did we win?
Yay.
Stick the legal tender
in my RFS, please. Right?
I know every once in a while you
have one of those things, right?
But you know what, 99% of the time
in basketball that doesn't happen.
And you just sitting there letting
six months, six minutes to your life,
go by to watch 45 seconds of action,
you know,
I dunno. So anyways, so I go to a
buddy's, my house buddy's house,
a buddy of mine's house. There we
go. It's actually an apartment.
What do you have to
exaggerate, bill? You don't,
why you're trying to enhance your life.
And I go fuck yourself. All right?
So I drive over to his apartment,
right?
And he lives in this part of the city
where there's no fucking parking.
And I'm really trying not to lose my shit.
I'm trying to control my temper.
Okay.
Cause I don't want to be this guy.
I really don't. I'd like to be that.
I'd like to be jolly.
I like to eat some pizzas,
some cookies now my stomach hanging out
underneath my sweater and nobody gives
me shit about it. Right? Oh um, so
yeah.
What am I, so I get my fucking
Prius and I drive down the road.
I can't find the parking. So I say fuck
it. You know I'm going to park at a meter.
So I park at the meter and I reached
into my little fucking console to get out
my little Baggie,
a quarters and oh and I forgot the not
there cause that cunt broke my fucking
window in my driveway,
broke the window,
my fucking car and stole a bag of
quarters. We say good, this Dosha,
right. And then I have to
pay for the fucking window.
So I pull up to the meter and I don't
have a Goddamn, I don't have any quarters.
I don't have any quarters.
Sorry guy.
Evidently I have to use my credit card.
Something I don't like doing.
I don't like using my credit card on a,
you know,
in a parking meter on a parking meter.
I don't like doing that because there's
a record that I was there. Okay.
Now I stick that thing in and that takes
a lot of stuff off the table for me.
Okay. I can't like get into a fight
with somebody and he pulls a knife,
we wrestle for it and
he falls on it and dies.
But I have no connection
to him and you know,
and I can't just fucking leave
without getting caught. Right?
I can't call somebody a cunt. This
does. I mean, I can do all that stuff,
but there's that, that the paper trail,
he was there. No, I wasn't. Yes you were.
We got your credit card.
Well, I didn't call her a con.
Why'd you lie about being
there? All right. Listen,
am I being charged with anything?
Because if I am, I want a lawyer. If not,
I'm fucking leaving. All right? Remember
that first 48 that's what you say.
So anyways, so I've got to use the fucking
credit card. So I use a credit card.
All right?
All I can get is two hours of time.
There's an hour and
something on the meters.
So I'm trying to pave the 20 minutes.
It's all fucking confusing.
I gave them two hours
of time for 20 minutes.
So go on and walk in this guy's fucking
apartment. I watched the Goddamn game,
right? I'm thinking two hours is
going to be enough. Timeout, timeout,
file, file, file, time out, all
that fucking bullshit. Right?
But time I figured out what's going on.
It's three and a half hours late and I'm
like, God, Jesus Christ, you're an idiot.
Bill. You've forgotten. You've
parked at a fucking meter.
You're going to have a ticket, right?
And I come walk it down the street
and I'm walking up to my car.
What do I see the fucking meter
maid who's a guy pulls up.
I still call them meter maids.
Even if it's a guy,
you know what kind of a
fucking man does that job?
I don't give a shit if it is a recession,
go break into somebody's Prius
to be a man about it, right?
I see the fucking meter maid man pulls
up and right as I'm there and I'm
laughing my ass off going,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
I got away with it and I jumped in
my Prius and I drive away. Wa Ha ha.
Laughing my ass off. Call up my buddy gay
wouldn't believe it. I got there, right.
It's a fucking blah, blah, blah.
Yeah, you had to be there, right?
I'm all thinking this is the fucking
greatest story ever. All right.
Put My car in the fucking driveway.
I don't know what I did after that.
Came inside at a couple of whiskeys and
I yelled at everyone in the House that I
love, you know, typical evening for me.
So the next morning I wake up and I
looked at the side of my car and evidently
somebody hit hit my fucking car. I'm
driving away last night, you know,
I'm driving away thinking, oh, look at me.
I've got to wait from the
fucking meeting maybe.
And somebody caved in the
entire side of my fucking car.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is about.
My Prius has just fucking,
every fucking three days,
somebody smashes into it.
I just can't keep the dead side of it.
You know?
I'm not one of these douchebags who gets
a fucking car and when something breaks
you just say fuck it. You leave it
that way. And next thing you know,
you look like Lamont drive it
over to Fred Sanford House.
I'm not going out like that. Even if it is
a Prius, I'm keeping it nice. All right.
I get the fucking thing detailed.
Yeah.
I don't give a shit. I get to fucking
interior shampooed I keep it nice.
Not riving around some, you
know, sorry. Bad enough.
I'm driving around on something that
it has bicycle tires on top of that and
have fucking Denson it all right.
I've got an image here of
people I'm trying to keep up.
Ah, Christ. I'm so fucking tired right
now. I don't want to do this. God Damn,
I didn't, what the fuck I'm
talking. What am I talking about?
That's how you guys are.
So Sandra Bernhardt this weekend,
I didn't do any standup.
I went down and, uh,
Whitney and her momma went down and we
saw Sandra Bernhardt down at the La Jolla
playhouse or something like that.
And uh, she's fucking awesome.
God Damn Rock Star.
You know,
it's kind of a cabaret thing was she
would sing songs and that type of stuff.
You know, and I think I was the only
straight guy. They're under the age of 45.
But I loved it. I actually wished
that she would do more standup.
She was fucking hilarious and a,
I don't know,
she was just,
that perfect kind of just not giving
a fuck. Just an absolute beast.
I've always been a huge fan of hers and
uh, so if you get a chance to see her,
I definitely fucking recommend it.
Yeah.
The fuck was she gonna she went off on,
she did like fucking 10 minutes on
Gwyneth Paltrow just trashing her.
It's phenomenal. And all
his shit about, you know,
watching TV and make it fun as
Cindy Crawford's stupid Cindy serum,
all that Shit I did.
It was phenomenal night.
I actually got to sit and watch somebody
else do stand up for once you don't
stood in line. Bought a DVD for Nia.
Right. And then stick out my ana.
But convenient though. All right.
Did that, took a picture? You know,
I had a little fan boy night.
It was nice.
Okay,
and so mass holistic cave in
the side of my fucking car.
Oh Jesus.
What the hell am I talking about?
I don't know what I'm talking about
anymore. You know? You know what?
I think it's time for people.
I think it's time for a fucking
commercial new this week, a blow pops.
You remember those things at the ice
cream man used to sell those red,
white and blue rockets teaches
the girls how to suck Dick. Nice,
right? Well, they're on sale
people. They're on sale this week.
If they're an ice cream truck comes by,
you just mentioned this podcast.
He just yell out,
Hey,
my sister's already sucking Dick and
I'll give you 10% off a blow pop.
All right. Nah, what the fuck am I
talking? Sorry, I don't have the,
I don't have the copy in front of me.
Where the hell is it?
Okay,
the fuck is wrong with it.
Why wouldn't I have any of this out
there to see advertising schedule here?
What do we got? stamps.com again, do I
really need to go through this again?
stamps.com everybody, you
know, you know the deal.
How would you like to have the post
office and your own apartment? But Phil,
I don't think,
relax.
I don't mean literally
stamps.com everybody.
Have you ever been sitting around rubbing
your balls at one in the morning going,
God, I wish I could put a
stamp on a letter. Well,
with stamps.com that
dream is now a reality.
Okay, so why don't you call
Oprah and start crying about it?
Because your dreams have
come true. All right? Look,
no one wants to go down
to the post office. It's a
dangerous place to go, okay?
Every six weeks somebody is down
there doing something crazy, right?
There's always some homeless guy,
you know,
holding the door for you as you walk in
and then expects you know that you're
going to pay him on the way out.
Like that's how life is.
Like that's how quickly you get
a return investment. You know,
like, I couldn't open that door
myself. You filthy son of a bitch.
Why do you want to deal with death again
about when you go in there and there's
some old lady trying to mail
or dentures to Cincinnati,
you don't want to stand behind that.
How do I weigh it?
Or It'd be nice if you had a scale in
your own apartment, a house, a dwelling,
or even your cubicle.
All you gotta do people's,
go to stamps.com you can buy and print
official us postage on your own computer
and you can print out those stamps.
Everybody, what'd you think?
You would just going to stare at them on
the screen. They got it all figured out.
All right. stamps.com we'll also give you
a digital scale to weigh your packages.
You type in the zip code is very easy.
I've been spending all my DVDs. It's,
it's amazing.
It is amazing.
Right now stamps.com is a
special offer for my listeners.
All 17 of them use my last name,
bur bur are all capital letters.
You get a no risk trial plus $110 bonus
offer that includes a digital scale and
$55 in free postage. Okay. I
don't know what else you need.
Go to stamps.com before you do
anything else, click on the microphone.
The radio microphone at
the top of the homepage,
you'd type in burr that stamps.com
everybody enter birth. How was that?
Was that a nice read?
I think it was like there was just
enough comedy in there while I got the
information out to um,
oh Jesus. So anyways, I live in this
old ass house. All right. And uh,
whoever lived here before, I don't think
it's the people right before the people,
for them, people for them.
This is a great old house.
And the great thing about having an old
houses, they have these old fixtures,
doorhandles hinges,
other handles, you know,
would carbons, all that type of
stuff. That makes the thing unique.
You know what the worst is,
is when somebody lives in the house before
you and they don't fucking appreciate
it. And what they do is they take
all those wonderful features.
They take 'em out and they go down to
home depot and they buy some plastic hunk
of shit. And he used that as a God
damn door handle. Well, you know what,
that's not how I roll.
Am I really going to talk about
brass door handles at this point?
Is that how far the fucking podcast
is? Com. I got a fucking door handle.
It's made out of brass and it has
90 years of Schmutz on it. Okay.
Fatty Arbuckle banged a whore up against
it probably sometime in the early
thirties and that what's from that horse?
Twat is still on the door handle. Okay.
And I went out and bought myself a little
fucking kid and I'm trying to Polish
that thing today.
And I realized how annoying it must have
been to work for rich people back in
the day.
We had to polish up their candelabra
has in their fucking spoons in it.
Tea Cups.
Oh my God.
I would fucking rub my balls on all their
fucking forks and everything before I
put them in the drawer. And there's
no way these people didn't do that.
There is nothing more annoying.
And I know these people back in the day
had no idea what an iPad was. You know,
they had no idea what it'd be like to
have live streaming porn on some little
fucking plastic box right on that table
where they could rub one out whenever
they wanted to. I realized it was a
simple time, you know, back in the day,
like an apple was a dessert, at least
according to my research, it was,
remember that back in the day he'd watched
those Tom Sawyer movies and they'd be,
hey, whitewash my fence and I'll
give you an apple boy. Oh boy,
you're fucking apple kid. Couldn't believe
it. I don't understand. You figured.
Then there was a whole bunch
of apple trees all around.
Why don't you go climb went
up, you'd dumped. Fuck,
you wouldn't have to paint the fence.
It's you really thought about it.
But then again,
he was an orphan.
It wasn't Tom Sawyer and orphaned was
the huck Finn. I don't fucking know.
What am I talking about?
Anyways, to be back in the day,
just have to sit there and shine up all
these fucking rich people's bullshit.
You know,
I bought this you that you can't afford,
make it even Shinier and you've
got to sit there doing that.
You know the same motion
over and over again.
The fucking your knuckles swelling up,
right?
Just sitting there,
you know going and I always to,
I always want to drive a stage coach.
And that dream just never happened for
you and that you are your whole fucking
life. You got to sit there and
shine spoons, not wash them.
You got to wash them and then
he got a fucking shine him up.
Let me tell you something.
I fuck with this brass door handle
for about 20 minutes. And I was like,
you know what? Fuck this. No, I didn't.
I went on Youtube and actually looked
up how to shine a breast fucking door.
So now I'm going down to the
fucking hardware store in
tomorrow and I'm going to
get some fucking low grade or high grade
fucking Sos pad and I'm going to do
that with a little toothbrush tomorrow.
Shine this son of a bitch up
and somehow I feel like it's
going to fill the void. Oh God.
Can you guys fill me slowly going crazy.
Um,
well if you can, I don't give a fuck
a YG. If he been wondering, you know,
I've realized that full ever. I haven't
even told you guys how to email me. Um,
it's bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
All right,
bill at, that's the, the a
with the circle around it.
Like Walt Disney drew it right.
bill@thempodcast.com.
Okay.
I said it three times. If you can't
figure it out, go fuck yourself.
I don't need to say go fuck yourself
because we are trying to email me to tell
me I gave you the wrong email.
I'm not going to get it. Um,
you can either go there or
go or [inaudible] or go to
bill bird.com/contact and
contact is spelled the
American way. C o n. T a Ct.
Okay. Not the Hungarian ways that a
fucking moth. You've got damn cons.
I need a uh,
God,
you motherfucker buy an old
house that has such character.
Hang on a second. I'm going to kill
that fucking thing and risk losing.
All my Peter listeners.
Hang on.
Yeah, that's it. That's what
happened. That's how that ended.
All right.
I'm back.
One less moth in the house
trying to eat my fucking sweat.
The mothballs work or let's like
ice cubes in the drink of moths.
Do they? Cause I swear to God, I got it.
I got mothballs all over the
fucking place and he's got, it's,
I think that throwing them in a high
ball glass as they fucking shout out my
turtlenecks. Um, I
dressed like Dick Cavett.
Now did I tell you guys that anyways,
the
contact
link@thetopofbillbillboarddotcomisabillatthemandpodcast.com
or
billboard.com/contact.
Send me an email. You know,
let me know you listen and do it.
Don't do it. Who gives a fuck?
Do you even give a fuck at this point?
I think a lot of my listeners right
now are just sitting with their hands.
They head on their hand,
just staring off into space.
And I gotta be honest with you.
That's exactly how I feel.
I just don't have time to do this tomorrow
morning. So I'm doing it right now.
You know what I mean? It's Kinda of like
when you're building a toy for your kid,
you don't really want to do it. You
know, you just plowing through it.
You're not even thinking about the joy
is going to have you just trying to get
to step eight. We could just finish
this whole fucking thing. Um, you know,
last week I brought up, uh, the
different types of cock blocks.
Last week I brought up the announcer that
who can cock block you from across the
room. Second, he sees something happening.
Hey,
what's going on?
All right.
That guy,
you know that he goes slowly slide
your hand back down to thigh,
back from out from underneath
the dress. You know, you just,
you just felt we have a good time.
So it was another type of cock block.
Evidently this person
named the double oh seven.
This is the friend of the girl you're
trying to hook up with or who acts like
she's in diff and acts like
she's indifferent about
heading back to your PR or
what this the friend of the girl you're
trying to hook up with who acts like
she's indifferent about heading back to
your place or staying at the party but
is secretly texting 1000 reasons to her
friend as to why they should get the
fuck out of there. Oh that's
the worst. That's right.
Why don't you just man up and say I
don't want to bang you. I'm leaving. Um,
so anyways, just cause she's
not getting any attention.
Okay.
She's always got some stupid passive
aggressive look on her face as she's
texting and going on about why they
got to get to Mickey's cause everyone's
there. Mikey's cause every once
there. Yeah. It's always, you know,
is there anything worse than
the, you know, it's something,
what do you think is worse?
The Guy,
your buddy cock block on you or
the ugly friend of the hot girl?
You Know Martha.
That's cow.
Okay.
You know what,
I wish I did back in the day.
Okay.
Because I always tried to ignore that
person and just keep working on the other
girl.
Even though I wanted to tell the the
the fucking ugly one to go fuck herself.
It's always killed me that I never
did because it never worked out.
One set girls marathon. Come on, let's go.
Okay,
Marissa, you've had too much to drink
like that one. Like I just wished,
just one time I just said, I'm
sorry. No one wants to fuck you.
Sorry. You're athlete. We're
going your personality. Right.
I might as well have done that
because once that fucking God damn,
I Dunno what something big and
hairy. Abominable Snowman. Big Foot.
I don't. What if I was
fucking nuts? So sleepy.
I would have had something funny there.
You know,
once she starts fucking yell and
Marissa Girl's not going to bang you.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Shane's snack a bag. Well,
maybe you should just lean into
Marissa just to be like, Hey,
let me ask you a question. Why do you
hang out with such ugly women? You know?
Well, what's your deal? What are you
insecure or something? I can't say.
What are your insecurity?
You got to keep it about the other one.
Do you have any good looking friends?
Just something.
Just something so you
can go down swinging.
Yeah.
I have no idea. Why am I excited
about the baseball season start?
I haven't watched baseball since
David Ortiz flunked some tests and I,
so it was like, you know what? Fuck this.
For some reason I'm
excited about baseball.
Okay.
I don't know why that is. Well bill, we
don't know either. Can you figure it out?
Can you say something funny about it? Are
you just gonna just leave it out there?
All right. This guy wants
money. Advice. Jesus Christ.
There's no way I'm making an hour.
This is 27 minutes in and I'm flailing.
Absolutely flailing.
Um, so the damp towel,
um,
which rocky was that?
What was the one was that,
that was the one where Apollo creed
got fucking killed by the Russian.
I must break you right.
Those cheap bastards. Um,
money advice bill.
I'm an Otr truck driver.
What the fuck is that off track?
Okay.
Betting. What does that o t I
don't know what that is. All right,
I'll take your word for it.
I'm an Otr truck driver and have a
problem with blowing fucking money like a
politician.
I have a wonderful fiance with a great
head on her shoulders and she is great
with money. Uh, every time
I see the bank statements,
the balance is more and more so I know
she's doing a bang up job with our
finances. Well, let me
tell you something, sir.
You are one perceptive son
of a bitch. Um, Casein,
another beggar. And I know that
that must be a good thing. Um,
so what's the fucking problem
you say? Well, like I said,
I'm terrible with money,
so I got one of them.
I got one of them prepaid debit cards.
He literally wrote one of them.
I liked this guy,
talks like Elvis and every Tuesday payday,
my girl puts $50 on there
so I can get groceries.
That way I don't turn into one of these
fat shifts that eats every meal out out
of the Wendy's, out of the Wendy's.
Ah, God, this guy is great.
He's man and Dan loaded up at truck.
We go and do what they say can't be done.
We're gonna get some hookers
at the next truck stop.
We ain't can wear condoms and shoot some
drugs and we'll all get fuckin aids and
pass it all around. Um, well,
$50 is good for one week of groceries,
but it's like pulling fucking
and teeth for extra money.
Lock safe for drinks or some rubbers
now like for drinks or some extra
curriculars.
Am I an asshole for thinking I deserve
a few extra bucks or what the fuck bill,
by the way, Nia has a sexy fucking
voice and go fuck yourself.
Um,
are you an asshole for thinking you
deserve a few work? Starbucks? Absolutely.
The fact that that poor woman
is legally bound to you and you,
you have no concept of
how to hold on to money,
that would be like,
I mean,
you're a guy like you're supposed to
fucking earn a living to support a family,
right?
If you have no concept of that,
that would be like if she had no concept
of like how to have a baby or how to
blow somebody's, you know what I
mean? Cause that's what their job is.
Sucking Dick and make it
idiot.
Okay.
Ah,
God measured my end of the balls to run
for president after doing this podcast
for five years. How, how easy
would it be to take me down?
MMM.
Do.
Why don't you learn about money?
Do you really just want to float around
like with your fucking eyes wide open,
just not getting it and don't
you want to understand money?
She's given you 50 bucks a week.
You know why cause you to fucking stupid.
He gets 60 and I'm sure you can
crawl under a truck and modify it.
I'm not saying you straight across
the board dumb but to not to not to
understand money.
It's,
I swear to God dude is one of
the dumbest things you honestly,
and this is for everybody.
It's one of the dumbest things you could
ever do in life is I understand not
understanding money up to about 1819 but
once you're to the point where you can
go to a library, we can go on the Internet
and you can just just read up on it,
okay?
You don't understand money.
You're going to be behind the eight ball
for your entire fucking life and you're
basically going to be an indentured
servant to credit card companies and banks
and your life is going to suck
way more than it needs to. Okay?
I'm not saying that just because
you understand money. When he a kid,
these isn't going to shit the bed.
Bad Shit's already going to happen.
You don't need to compound it
with not understanding money.
All right,
this woman is the best thing that
ever fucking happened to you.
You don't understand money and you
want monit for drinks and some extra
curriculars. What does
that mean? An eight ball?
If you start with drinks and then you say,
I like how safe or drinks or some extra
curriculars like boozing to you isn't
even an extra curricular
activity. That's just, you know,
let's like nourishment few.
So I'm,
I'm assuming that extra curriculars is
at least a bag of weed or maybe some
condoms to bank some trucker
whore, truck stop whore, you know?
Listen sir,
you got a great fucking woman,
but she's only gonna put up with you not
understanding money for so long because
at some point she's going
to want a god damn man.
Okay.
Especially once you have a couple of kids,
she doesn't need you
being some adult kids.
So I would say read up on money and
you'd understand what a favor she's doing
for you. If you, if your
bank balance is going up,
you're doing better than 90% of
the people out there. All right?
So here's a good thing.
You got to fucking angel and she's
smart and just read up on money.
All right? She's also keeping
in shape. Go buy groceries.
Don't become a tub of shit.
You know,
she's basically without you even
realizing or possibly even her,
she's laying down the gauntlet here.
She's basically saying
in her own cute way.
I don't want to be married to
some fat broke trucker. All right,
so read up on money.
Keep eating your fucking pears and fruit
out there and a and you'll be fine.
All righty. There you go. Alright.
Hyphenating name a bill. My girl
was thinking about hype, uh,
of hyphenating. Did I say
hyperventilating earlier?
I can't even remember. Five
seconds ago. I'm this sleepy.
My girl was thinking of hyphenating
her name when we get married.
I'm not some archaic,
Patriarchal Nutcase,
but I think the whole concept is
absolutely ridiculous for one reason.
First of all, I love that. If you,
if you even disagree with some fucking
horseshit a woman's going to do at this
point, you always have to say,
no, I'm not some caveman, um,
sort of use goes. I think it's
absolutely ridiculous. For one reason.
Say we have a daughter and our daughter
wants to be like mommy and get her name
hyphenated.
Then she will have three names.
If she has a daughter does the same thing,
she will have four names.
Absolutely ridiculous.
Your thoughts? Yeah.
I would say that women hyphenating their
last names is basically the same as
that's like their prenup,
you know,
so they can just drop you off.
You know, if you get divorced,
they can just sort of chop you
off like an appendix, you know,
like you're this thing that
isn't really necessary,
but for some reasons it's still there,
but you can live without it, you know?
Um, look, she's either
marrying you or she isn't.
Okay.
Cause I gotta be honest with you when I'm
on the road in some married woman with
a hyphenated name comes up to me.
I think I'm 50% in the game.
Hey, I'm not fucking Sarah and
Russell. I'm just trying to fuck Sarah.
Anne, why don't you drop
the Russell to not baby? No,
I'm just fucking with you.
What do I think about that? Um,
yeah,
I dunno. A woman with a hyphenated
last name to me that's a red flag.
That's a red flag that says to
me that she does want a husband.
She wants a wife.
Uh,
she's going to be a terrible mother
and she's going to focus on her career.
That's what I think. But then
again, I'm ignorant. You know,
what are you gonna be
[inaudible] Zimbalist Jr.
What does a good fucking hyphenated
name doesn't? That chick who, uh,
that raven haired beauty. Who married
Michael Douglas? Isn't her name? Like a
from Zito Jones.
Catherine Zeta Jones Douglas. Is that how
she has it? She just kept her last name.
Look at me and Nia ever get fucking
marriage. She goes, I don't want to take
your last name or I want to hyphenate it.
I'd be like, you know, it just, you know,
don't fucking, you know, don't, don't,
don't pander to me here.
All right.
I, you just either you're fucking
taking my name where you're not,
you're not doing this fucking hyphenated
shit. Give your own last name.
I don't give a fuck,
but our kids are going to have my last
name because I'm the God damn man and I'm
stronger than you. That's how it's going
down. I gotta be honest with you. I don't,
that hyphenated name thing
is fucking weird to me.
I think you should either just be like,
look, I'm not taking your, your last name.
And it just be done with it. Or the
hyphenated name is, uh, you know,
I noticed that a lot of chicks, uh, on,
on Facebook do that so they
can get in touch with guys.
They used to bang back in high school
and college so he can still be found,
you know, that's what
I think. There you go.
I think she's got a wild streak in her.
I don't think she's ready to settle down.
She doesn't want that barn door to close.
She'll go into the bomb.
Don't close that door. She's going to
start kicking, um, advice. Hey Bill,
I need some advice. Oh, I didn't give you
any way. What do you think about it? Yeah,
I think it is fucking ridiculous.
All right.
Just say, look, if I'm going to pay for
your fucking life, who's kidding? Who?
That's what's going to happen.
You got to pay for it one way or another.
You are going to pay for it.
You're gonna have most of the fucking
financial responsibilities and you're
going to die before she does. That's
basically how it goes, you know?
Can you at least just take my fucking
last name and act like you're with me.
Fucking unappreciative son of a bitch.
Advice a bill.
I need some advice badly.
Uh,
I got a fucking delicate situation I'm
working with and I'm not sure how to
handle it. I swear to God this is
how this guy's writing. I like,
it's very conversational.
A little pertinent. Uh,
first I'm 20,
I'm a 20 year old living with my parents.
My 21st is the 20th.
It's like a math problem for train
leaves at 20 in the 21st is on the 20th.
Um, mid April. I plan
on getting a vasectomy.
I do not want advice about this.
Well, you're going to get judged.
What are you low?
You will those population people.
I haven't gotten laid in
about a year and a half story.
Last Friday the ninth, there was a
party at a friend's house. Kelly's,
her parents were out of town
and she was a senior and Ah,
what did I say?
Her name is she of age.
Everyone was drinking lots of fun
parties winding down and we go upstairs.
Saturday morning, I woke up in her bed,
we go to breakfast, had a real nice time.
Saturday night, I go over
no party, just great sex.
I suggest a new position.
She loses her mind,
says it was the best sex of her life.
It's a great story so far.
What could go wrong? As we're cuddling,
falling asleep Saturday into Sunday,
I casually suggest that we should
never date and she completely agrees.
Oh my God, this girl's a fucking
angel. What could go wrong?
Right back step a little bit.
I broke up with my very
unserious girlfriend and also
a senior at the same high
school about two or three
weeks ago saying, I want a
more serious relationship.
Completely true. Uh,
the fucking challenges.
Should I try and keep this thing
going or quit while I'm ahead?
Uh, the only potential
downside is if word gets out.
It would put a lot of strain on the
relationship with one of my extremely good
friends. Also, my ex best friend are,
I see a bang in your x
best friend's girlfriend.
Uh, do I need to read
the rest of this? Yeah.
Quit while you're ahead,
dude,
unless you don't give a
shit about your best friend.
MMM,
yeah. That's what I would do. I
would get the fuck out. Let me,
let me reread that again in case
I messed. Messed it up. Sorry.
I'm fucking half asleep here. The only
potential downside is if word gets out.
He'll put a lot of Susan as a, with
one of my extremely good friends. Also,
my ex ex,
his best friend.
Dude, I can't do the math on that. I'm
too fucking tired. Itchy. I you obviously,
you're basically,
as far as I can tell,
there's a cocktail party right around
the corner and you're on just the other
side of the wall banging the bosses. Girl
says something going on it yet, Dude.
Get the fuck out. Pull the ripcord. You
banged her. It was great. You're young.
It's going to be another Ra
that there's going to be others.
Don't worry about it. All
right. All I can tell you this.
Don't get a vasectomy so you don't
have to wear a condom. Wear a condom.
All right. Definitely do that. You
don't need that shit. All right.
You don't need any of that shit that comes
along with dead fucking level. Christ,
what do we have two guys?
Can I tap out early?
You guys ever go sick early on a
Friday. You go home, I a tummy ache.
I want to go home.
Right?
And then you go down to the local bar
and you start fucking drinking, right?
Then all of a sudden,
some girl in a gene fucking skirt starts
dance a little provocatively and next
thing you know, yell and
college. Boy, you're next, right?
Um, God Lord, was that an accused? Yes,
it was a Bon Jovi car. Everybody.
I'm blown. Hey, you know what?
I think it's time for advertising.
Oh,
great timing on this one. Um, oh,
amazon.com everybody,
if you're thinking about buying any,
let me just get through all the
fucking ads so we can get back to the
unbelievably mediocre level of
funny that I'm bringing this week.
amazon.com everybody. All
right. If you think going to go,
you thinking about buying something,
not saying you got it,
but if you thinking of buying something,
all right on amazon.com and you'd like
to contribute to my podcast without it
costing you one more dime.
Just go to Amazon dot. Go,
go, go the level or backup.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
click on the podcast page.
You look on the right hand side,
you'll see an amazon.com banner.
All right, one for America,
one for UK, and one for Canada.
Click on whatever country you're in.
And the second you go there,
whatever you buy,
they give me a little kickback and I
take 10% of the kickback and I give it to
the wounded warriors project.
There you go. Bing, Bang,
boom.
All done.
He donated to the podcast and you
helped out the wounded warriors.
And I just realized, you know, we'd be
fucked up is what if I got a Afghanistan,
amazon.com in 10% of it went to
the wounded warriors. You know,
I don't think I'd sell anything over
there. Um, game, fly.com everybody.
It's the best way to rent video
games. Over 8,000 games. No late fees.
Cancel any time.
Introducing Unlimited PC play
Monday morning podcast listeners.
You get a 15 day free trial,
15 f in days of 8,000 games
free delivered to your house,
free right to your PC. Okay?
All you do is go to Gamefly,
www dot [inaudible] dot com slash
burr to activate the special offer.
Look at that. Would you
look at that? Because of me?
You have the post office in your house.
Okay,
you're doing that while you hit
pause on 8,000 games. Incredible.
And then if you go to buy a
fucking beanie on amazon.com,
you can help out the wounded warriors,
you know,
and helped me make my garage doors
wider. Everybody's winning. Um,
here's something that's really
been doing well. The skate fenders,
people are buying them.
People are sending me emails
telling me they're loving him.
Tell him to taking pucks in their foot and
they can barely even feel, feel it. Um,
go to escape fenner.com and type
in the Promotional Code Bill Burr,
all lowercase. No, uh,
no space for $5 off scape fenders.
I highly recommend them.
I'm playing hockey tomorrow night.
I'm putting them on and I'm going to be
a shot block and motherfucker cause I
got protection on my feet. Skate
fender.com. All right, there you go.
That's it for those. That's it for
those. And Oh hey, do you see this shit?
Did you see this shit about the
fucking guy who's got the, you know,
he went over to, he went over to
Uganda, that Guy Kony Kony 2012.
You see that? You see how quickly
they brought that guy down?
This guy's shines a light on the,
uh, on himself first and foremost,
and how he and his child or dealing
with it, which was really bizarre.
I mean,
I don't know about you guys,
but it was enough for me to see the boy
soldier crying cause he saw his brother
have his next sliced right
in front of him, you know,
and he goes from that to be a,
now I'm going to sit my son down and
tell him about the, it's like, Whoa,
I didn't even get it.
All right.
So anyways,
this guy shines a light on this bullshit
that's going on over there and all of a
sudden everybody's in
an uproar of a sudden.
Everybody gives a fuck about Uganda
and these boys soldiers, you know?
Then all of a sudden the United States
government is going to do with fighting
two wars. We can't even afford to fight
one. Now this guy's bringing this shit up.
Gee, wouldn't it be nice if something
fucking happened that would discredit him?
Next thing you know, a
couple of days later, a,
this guy connected with the film from
Dec Kony 2012 gets caught jerking off in
public.
Was I the only guy who found that
unbelievably fucking convenient?
I didn't buy it for a second. In fact,
I tweeted, you know, back in the day,
they used to assassinate you. Now they
just do this. You know what I mean?
If they can make it look like
we landed on the moon in 1969,
you don't think that they can make you
anybody they want make it look like
you're rubbing one out in the
fucking parking lot. I don't buy it.
Okay.
What that fucking Douche bag was doing,
not douche bag. That fucking self-serving.
Cont there we go.
That's what I was trying to say.
What he was doing with that film was
he was putting pressure on the United
States to go over there and fucking
somehow insert themselves into that
situation, which would have cost
a ton of fucking money, you know?
But there's no way to be like,
hey, fuck those boys soldiers,
you know, because of the,
uh, the way the coop,
because of what it says in our pamphlet,
you know, give a shit or your week,
give us your poor and will exploit
the shit out of them and uh,
let him die of tuberculosis in a
damp apartment. And then years later,
whoever made the most amount of
money gets a statue made out of them.
That's all in our thing.
So we can't look the other way
with these fucking boy soldiers.
So what's easiest thing to do? Just just
make that guy look like a freak show.
Okay.
First of all, who hasn't jerked
off in a parking lot? Honestly?
You know who hasn't done that?
You know,
you fucking girl goes in to change
something. You sit in there, your board,
you can't get any radio reception
cause you know, it's back in the day.
He just say, yeah, I'm bored. Right?
He got a girl in your life.
So you know,
there's gonna be some sort of Napkins
in the car. What are you going to dope?
Right? You got the captain's
chairs? No one could see ya.
Yeah.
Oh, this is taking forever. Hey,
what if I rub one out, right? Yeah.
Everybody's got a fucking camera.
You know,
you know what's amazing is that everybody
hasn't got caught jerking off in
public at this point. Everybody's got a
camera in their, uh, their cell phone.
What I'm trying to say people is I
don't buy it and it doesn't matter.
I don't give a fuck whether the guy from
Coney was jerking off in a parking lot
or not. That doesn't change whether
or not this boy soldiers in Uganda.
But what's great is,
is then the conversation switches from
what's going on over there to low let's
this guide Dylan,
he's he rubbing his deck like we all do
and then everybody would be like,
yeah, but we don't do it in public out.
So what that makes you better.
It doesn't make you better.
It just makes you more considerate,
doesn't it?
I mean if you had two people and they
were both shooting heroin and one person
had the decency to do it in their house
and the other person does it out in
public, at the end of the
day, you both drug addicts.
So if you're really going to sit there
and shit on this guy for jerking off,
then you would have to
basically be not jerking off
at all.
Right.
Ladies and gentlemen of the jury,
I'm asking you to look into your hearts.
If you have not rubbed one out,
let he who is not rubbed one
out in some sort of pump. No,
you'd have a jerked off at work.
God, I'm fucking bored. Excuse me,
let me go to the bathroom. Maybe they
think I'm taking a shit standing up.
Right.
Come on.
If you're a guy in your arms along enough,
at some point you've jerked off in
some place where you shouldn't have.
You jerked off to somebody you
shouldn't have. You've done it.
We've all been there.
Who gives a fuck?
There's still boys fighting in
wars over this. So you know,
if you want to help out, help
out. If you don't, don't,
but don't let some guy rubbing
one out in a parking lot.
Change your mind either way.
You know what they're doing right now
that doing what women do when they argue
when they start to lose is they bring
up other shit and they spin it into a
different room.
And next thing you know,
you're arguing a whole different argument
and argument that they wanted you to
fucking argue.
So they knew that they could win rather
than keeping the argument on fucking
track of saying,
listen sweetheart,
I don't like the way you fucking
been dressing lately. Okay?
I gotten this relationship to treat
you like a piece of fucking meat.
All right? And lately you've
been slacking off. Oh God.
Let me adjust my weight. Maybe the
funnies on this side of the couch. Um,
what else? What do we got here? Come on
bill. You got another 11 minutes? Huh?
You know, I feel like right now,
like if I was in the tort of fraud,
I would actually, I would be in
the Pyrenees right now. All right.
And My podcast is that one bald
motherfucker with the bracelet.
And he just looked back at
me to see all I'm doing.
He seen my fucking mouth hanging open
and now he's going into fucking second
gear and I'm going to lose this stage.
Okay.
Except the Lance Armstrong is
my fucking podcast this week.
If he didn't get the metaphor,
was that a metaphor?
It wasn't as similarly
similarly is like her as right.
My podcast is like, I always want to say
Greg Lamont. What a Douche that guy is.
Greg Lamont. I still can't get over
how he talks trash about Lance fucking,
uh, all worth whatever the fuck
his name is. What does it lance,
what went lance Whitaker, you
only won seven bike races. Bill.
What the fuck you've ever done? Did I
ever even win a bike race in my childhood?
You know,
I try to beat my brother one time in a
bike race and that mother fucker always
beat me because he had big legs,
you know,
and I had little legs,
little bitchy lakes,
and our driveway was a hill. And so we
don't, and we lived on this busy street,
so we'd always have to fucking
stop and then, you know,
look both ways and then cross the
fucking streets. So from a dead stop,
I can have a good,
I could have a beat this son of a bitch.
So one day we'll race and home and I
come up with a brilliant fucking idea.
I'm like in second grade,
I know what I'll cross while we're racing.
When he goes to stop,
I'll be all we going up the driveway and
I'll get to beat him and his fucking Bo
Jackson thighs right up the goddamn
driveway. And uh, I swear to God,
I turned around and I looked,
evidently I didn't look well enough and
I fucking pulled out right in front of a,
a jeep and all I heard was
boom, right. Next thing you
know, I'm fucking upside down.
Okay.
And I vaguely remember seeing the bumper
and feeling the heat of the engine at.
Uh, and then like, I dunno,
like two seconds later I was open my
eyes and I was laying across the yellow
double line on the road.
I was out for like literally like fucking
five seconds long because by the time
I stood up to get out of the street,
the guy in the jeep had already got out
this big son of a bitch and he was crying
and he came up and he's like,
I'll buy a new bike.
My bike was all mangled and all I was
thinking was my dad's going to fucking
kill me for fucking up my bike
because that's how it was in the 70s.
All right.
I know if that happened to a kid nowadays,
my parents would have sued the guy in
the jeep for everything he was fucking
worth.
And then bought me a bicycle made out of
gold and that guy's four o one k plan.
Right?
But this was the 70s people didn't sue.
People yelled at kids for being dumb
when they did dumb shit. So I was like,
oh my God, they're going to fucking kill
me and my bike's all fucking mangled.
And um, then I went to the
hospital, we'll taxi cab.
I told this story before.
I remember that I told you I got hit
right on the side of the fucking head.
It happened on a Wednesday.
I remember it happened on
a Wednesday because then I
didn't have to go to school.
The Guy said he has to go to
school for the rest of the week.
So I've got Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
Sunday off and all was fucked up about me,
was on the side of my head. Puts
you, put your fingers on the side of,
get your temples right now, right.
And bite down on your molars.
You doing that already know you feel
that little thing that goes in and out.
That's right where I got hit.
So it hurt to chew.
So for four days I was a little spoon.
I didn't know I was just such,
it was fucking awesome.
I didn't have to fake sick and they have
to pretend that I was sick and for four
days,
which is a goddamn maternity.
Yeah,
I got to fucking chill out.
54 minutes.
Um Oh God, Jesus Christ. I don't know how
you fucking people do this. This is like,
this is like your work week. Isn't
it just staring at the fucking clock.
Um,
or you know,
it was make fun of how Bon Jovi can
somehow sell out giant stadiums in New
Jersey, but for some reason can't sell
out a, a fucking Denny's. And in Oregon,
I don't even know if that's true.
I just like shitting on him. Um,
somebody wrote and said, hey
bill, I love the podcast.
I know one of your vaccine questions of
our age is why the fuck is Bon Jovi so
popular in New Jersey? I get that they're
from, from there by giant stadium.
Anyways, he goes, I'm a u s service
members stationed overseas in Germany.
When I first moved here two years ago,
I saw a Volkswagen in my town with a
Bon Jovi sticker on the side of the car.
I thought,
Holy Shit,
that is one dedicated fan and wouldn't
be funny if VW really made a Bon Jovi
edition of the vehicle while I started
seeing the car elsewhere in Germany.
And finally I googled it.
It's real.
The attach photo is a picture I
took on the base of a VW Bon Jovi.
Yeah. And it's not a sticker.
It's literally like the emblem,
like on the side of your car.
If it says Prius or Monte Carlo.
Right. Um, isn't that funny? That
Chevy named that car. A Monte Carlo.
You ever seen Monte Carlo Monte Carlo
that's in France and it has like fucking
like that's all the Illuminati money
in an America. It's some shitty accent.
Shitty. It's a good looking car.
Back in the 80s, it was, but come on,
you know there was a poor man's caddy.
It's a poor man's Buick anyways.
They actually, it's, it's the
uh, yeah, like, like whatever.
It's the make not the make
not to make,
what the fuck is it? They say make
type. I don't fucking know. I'm sleepy.
It's on the side of the God damn fucking
car. We got a picture of it, everybody
in order to feel like right now,
I feel like one of those guys who gives
those double decker tour bus guys,
you know, and I don't know shit about
the city and I will give a fuck.
Somebody hooked me up with a job. I
sort of feel like, um, and it was,
that's the podcast for this
week. Everybody, I apologize.
I take full responsibility.
This, I'm going to do this.
Like when an athlete blows a game and he,
the press is going to trash them.
So he just jumps on the fucking grenade
before they throw it in his face.
I take full responsibility for that loss.
Said I didn't, I didn't get it done.
I didn't get it done. All right. Shows
I have coming up. All right, you can't.
I want to be at the dupont theater.
Wilmington,
Delaware on March 30th
or March 35th 31st 35th,
Jesus Bill, wake up. March 31st
the cavalcade of humor continues when
bill burr shows up to Massachusetts own
bill Burroughs shows up to the
music hall in Troy, New York.
On April 1st I'll be at the Tarrytown
music hall with Paul [inaudible],
Paul [inaudible] near Jersey's
own, Paul Versey, who's a,
uh,
he's a jets and a giants fan.
He's one of those guys, whoever's
winning, he becomes a fan of them. Um,
April 27th, I'm doing a college
gig and this is open to the public.
This is very rare. This is a
situation that does not occur a lot.
Hence a rare situation. I'm going to
be at a Concord College in Concord,
New Hampshire.
All right.
On April 27th and I have all the
links here on a billboard.com.
You just click on shows and then you
click on the go button next to the Gig.
You want to go to the next thing you know,
you go into the fucking show unless you
girl gets sick and doesn't want it go.
And then you got to eat
the fucking tickets. Renew,
resent her when she falls asleep.
You give,
give her paper cuts with tickets
between her toes. Um, June 15th,
16th and 17th. I want to be in
San Jose, California. Vacationing.
No, I want to be at the Improv. San Jose,
California. June 15th through the 17th.
And if that's,
if that's city isn't enticing enough,
you could then it like the grateful dead.
Follow me to another luxurious city,
a place called Ontario,
California,
part of the inland empire that
conquered the middle region of southern
California hundreds of years ago.
Uh,
can we get the Ontario
Improv on June 29th,
30th and July 1st those are going to be
great shows because I hate that city.
So I will be extra conti and probably a
lot funnier than I am on this podcast.
And the last one I have for you, uh, for
you. White trash people. Anybody out?
They got a mullet wallet. I
got to, I got back to back,
back to back now, July
13th, 14th and 15th.
I'm at the Improv in West Palm Beach.
All right.
And if that isn't white trash enough for
you, I'm going to be in Orlando, Florida,
home of Disney world,
the Epcot Center. And uh,
the, uh, the day after pill, the
morning after, what do they call it?
A Orlando, Florida. And we had the Orlando
Improv September 7th, eighth and ninth.
And finally I'll be at the Bray
Improv September 21st 22nd,
23rd. And I know what you thinking while
bill, those are a lot of club dates.
That was a lot of shows you going to
do there. You're kind of fucking old.
What are you doing all those shows for
a while? I'll tell you why everybody.
I'm building up my new hour.
All right. I'm building up.
My new are supposed to learn how
to ride a fucking motorcycle today,
but it was supposed to rain so they,
everybody canceled it.
So hopefully next week I'll have some
stories about me trying to learn how to
ride a motorcycle or something.
Hopefully I'll have something remotely
remotely funny few people. Okay.
That's the podcast for this
week, everybody. And, uh,
I think it's very fitting for me to end
with the exact amount of energy I have
right now in this tone
of voice. All right. Oh,
youtube video of the week
for drummers out there.
Why don't you guys look up the drew
groove applied to the modern drum set.
Have all these videos up
on the, uh, I'm sorry,
on billboard.com on the podcast page.
There we go.
I'm actually doing this right
now with my eyes closed. Okay.
I'm trying to think of an artist who
used to perform with his eyes closed.
Mitch Hedberg the Great Mitch Hedberg.
So that's sack religious cause
I'm about one. 90th is funny.
Is that son of a bitch. Speaking
of funny Patrice O'Neal, everybody,
I know I mentioned it a while back.
Uh,
I want to thank all you guys
who went out and downloaded. Uh,
Mr p is CD was number one on iTunes
and a generate a lot of money for his,
uh, his mom. And if he cannot buy
any comedy or anything like that,
I I'd appreciate if you'd do
that, if you would by Mr p. Um,
I told you guys eventually I was
going to tell some stories about him,
but I'm still,
uh,
still stunned by that whole situation
and I don't want to talk about itself at
some point I will. But anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Please download Mr p, uh, amazon.com
all that type of shit. Um,
and that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
Have a good week. Don't take any shit,
Dan. Yeah. People are still
boy soldiers in Uganda,
whether or not that guys rubbing one
out or open in his ass for the world to
see.
Don't ever forget that.
Don't lose sight of
what the real story is.
Okay?
That is all good night.
And God bless the United
States of America.